Authorities in Russia have
launched a murder investigation
after a prominent pro-war
military blogger
was killed in a blast
at a cafe in St Petersburg.
Loveland to task died in that explosion,
which happened
during an event
hosted by a pro-war group on Sunday.
More than 30 others were injured.
State media reports
that investigators have been questioning
everyone
who was inside the cafe at the time.
Let's take you now live to London,
where CNN's Clare
Sebastian is standing
by monitoring developments for you
Claire.
Let's start with that deadly bomb attack
in Saint Petersburg.
Has anyone claimed responsibility
No one has claimed responsibility.
But I can tell you that
Russian state news agency
RIA Novosti is now reporting
that the Interior Ministry
has placed a 26 year
old Saint Petersburg
resident named Daria Trepova
on their wanted list.
It says that she is wanted
under an article of the Criminal Code.
It does not say which one.
But we now have that name
and of course her date of birth,
which puts her at 26 years old.
She has been named in state
media reports as a potential suspect
in this matter.
RIA Novosti has spoken to eyewitnesses
at the scene who say they saw her hand
or a woman, not necessarily this woman,
but they saw a woman hand a figurine
to Vladlen Tatarsky
who was at an event
where he was
speaking, and that the explosion happened
shortly after that.
So these are the details
that are emerging from that event.
In terms of political reaction,
not much as of yet.
We've heard
only really from the Foreign Ministry
spokeswoman, Maria
Zakharova, who said
that Russian journalists,
she said, are
constantly experiencing
threats of reprisals, reprisals
from the Kiev regime and its inspires,
which are increasingly being implemented.
They're pointing the finger
there at Ukraine.
Interestingly, Yevgeny
Prigozhin, a Viognier,
he has now come out
and pretty much admitted that this cafe
was affiliated with Wagner
and has said that he actually disagrees
with that,
that he thinks
this was probably a group of radicals
and not affiliated
with the government of Ukraine.
So a lot of speculation
at the moment flying around.
But we can see that given the scale
of the destruction
investigation, still ongoing
investigations are ongoing.
Claire, talk to us about the man
who was the target of this assassination,
Maxine Forman.
Yeah, Maxine,
formerly known
by his blog, a name of LED Interest,
which comes from a sort of postmodern
Russian novel by Bolivian
called Generation P.
Inspired by that,
he was part of a cohort of Russian
military bloggers
who really can see him there
in one of his videos,
offered a less
censored, more
raw view of what was happening
on the Russian side of the front line.
Then suddenly we get
from the Russian Ministry of Defense.
Another official source
says he was actually born in Ukraine,
fought from 2014 on the side of Russian
backed separatists in the Donbas
and then switched over
to becoming
a blogger, set up
his channel
in 2019
and amassed a really big following.
More than half a million people.
He moved in ultranationalist circles.
Interestingly, he has been photographed
with Daria Dugin,
who was assassinated in a car bomb
in August,
the daughter of an ultranationalist
ally of President Putin.
So an interesting character
has in the past
been critical
of how the special military operation
has been conducted.
Sebastian reporting.
Thank you so much, Claire
And the head of the Russian mercenary
group, Wagner, says
a Russian flag has been raised in memory
of the military blogger
on the battlefield in Bermuda.
All those comments from Yevgeny Prigozhin
coming in, a brief video
he claims was reported
in the eastern Ukrainian city.
CNN can't immediately
confirm the location
where Prigozhin recorded the message,
holding a flag
that was indistinct in the darkness